the widow of a murder New York City  police detective gave birth to their  child more than two years after his  death the healthy baby girl was born  yesterday in New York  the mother who goes by the name sani lu  used in vitro fertilization with sperm  that was preserved after her husband was  killed the baby is named Angelina she  was wearing an NYPD cap just after she  was born her father detective when Jen  Lu was shot dead in 2014 along with his  partner while they sat in a patrol car a  bittersweet moment they said that she  was asked that night in the hospital  which he liked to preserve some of the  sperm and she said yes the family is  very happy about it but you're right nor  bittersweet where we going well it's  just exactly what you guys yeah yeah  bittersweet but I'm glad they did it me  too they named the baby angel